thank you these students in Srinagar
should be at school instead their local
community center is doubling up as a
temporary classroom deputy school Bongo
Gadol I'll be hopping after the schools
were closed I started coming to this
community tuition center the staff teach
us well and I like to study here I have
made new friends and it feels like a
school now the community school was set
up after Parliament in New Delhi revoked
the special autonomous status of
indian-administered Kashmir seven weeks
ago the subsequent tension on the
streets left many parents afraid to send
their children to school and those
concerns persist we see kids playing on
the street so we come up with an idea
that we will start community tuition
centres to teach students there so that
they will not feel lonely some schools
have reopened in Srinagar but many like
this one remain closed
experts say the disruption to education
services will have a long-term impact on
students this is the most impressionable
age when you learn when you're learning
process should not get [ __ ] there
should be no blockades in this free flow
of learning and once you're putting
barriers in the free flow of learning
this is the death this is the withering
away of the students
Internet and mobile phone services in
Srinagar remain cut off for this PhD
student that means years of hard work
are in jeopardy
my first thesis which I recently
submitted has not been sent to the
referees outside because of the lockdown
as a result my PhD is stuck though I
have completed my dissertation and
submitted it students in
indian-administered Kashmir have grown
up surrounded by poverty and violence
the events over the last seven weeks
have made their already difficult lives
even harder
Victoria Gaytan be al-jazeera